bienvenue dans paf on va débattre de
l'actualité de la semaine avec Sephora
Dahmani bonjour Patrick avec Mustapha
Larbaoui bonjour Patrice
présidente du Football Club de Trappes
est-ce besoin de le préciser non non
avec Jean-Luc Madec Jean Patrice
éditeur avec un nouveau livre que j'ai
pas encore lu de Jérôme Zolma en main
propre un roman impola qui se passe
maintenant et en Algérie en 62 d'accord
alors on a un sommaire un peu chargé on
va parler évidemment des élections
régionales puisqu'il s'est passé quelque
chose de nouveau avec la candidature de
Claude Bartolone et sa passionne
Mustapha je crois
parler des trois autres de François
Hollande de la visite à Cuba de la
rencontre avec avec le leader maximo on
peut parler aussi peut-être des quotas
d'immigration est-ce qu'il faut des
quotas ou pas des quotas mais je
voudrais qu'on commence parce que vous
avez assisté hier à la finale de la de
la Champions League féminine PSG le PSG
a perdu les filles du PSG ont perdu vous
voulez dire un mot justement du football
et notamment du football féminin
Mustapha alors j'y ai assisté pour les
téléspectateurs j'ai assisté sur France
2 d'ailleurs un coup de chapeau à France
2 parce que je voulais vous faire bosser
mais pour Mustapha ça effectivement ça
voilà c'était pour dire que j'avais
assisté sur France 2 pour commencer par
dire à France 2 que c'était la première
fois qu'on avait un match de ce de ce
rang et surtout un match de football
féminin
alors j'ai pas les audiences j'ai pas
les audiences simplement quand les
filles ont prétendu vouloir obtenir des
primes de match puisque on parlait de
prime de par joueuse en cas de victoire
on a tout de suite fait le parallèle
avec les 1 million d'euros Champions
League simplement
le président du pêcheg et pour le même
président du PSG avait promis 5000 €
pour les féminines donc ça il y a eu un
peu le buzz sur cet événement simplement
c'est vrai que c'est souvent corrélé à
le dimat et à toute la pression
publicitaire qui peut y avoir autour je
serais curieux de savoir combien de
téléspectateurs à regarder le match en
tous cas moi je l'ai regardé je l'ai
regardé pour regarder pour que ça
déclenche l'audit en fait c'est en
dessous
il y a un seuil de tolérance il y a un
facteur de curiosité tu peux dire
Jean-Charles non il y a un facteur de
curiosité sur le football féminin qui
est indignable maintenant vous pouvez
pas dire et la différence des primes
s'explique par là que ce que ça génère
en publicité en sponsoring etc et le
même pour les hommes et pour les femmes
c'est ce que j'aime bien oui
et c'est pour ça que c'est primes aussi
sont différents c'est pas c'est c'est
pas pour une question d'inégalité entre
les hommes et les femmes c'est parce que
la différence est économique elle est
pas exactement ce que je viens de dire
c'est à dire que
la polémique qui est née de cette
différence de traitement et pas pour moi
une polémique qui avait force sur
l'égalité personnellement c'était
justement parce que il y avait pas
d'économies autour du football féminin
comme il y a l'économie autour du
football et c'est pour ça que j'étais
intéressé d'avoir le dimat mais je pense
que ça va être de plus en plus
grandissant de ce que Jésus
quand l'équipe de France a joué vous
avez fait des grosses comme ça marche
très très bien parce que les les
joueuses sont véritable bombe atomiques
elles sont sponsorisées oui non mais je
dis pas mais elles sont sponsorisées par
Victoria Secret la marque de lingerie
bien connue et après chaque but elles
enlèvent leur maillot parce que alors
effectivement c'est quand même beaucoup
plus sympathique
bien pour avoir regardé le match hier
Patrice encore une fois
des joueuses de foot de grande
expérience que j'ai vu mais ce que
j'avais envie de dire c'est que c'était
à la fois
le problème c'est dès qu'on commence à
parler de foot féminin il faut qu'on
fasse attention à ce qu'on va dire parce
que par définition quoi que je dis ça va
être taxer
au moins de sexisme c'est en ça que je
voudrais dire que je regarde un bon
match
de football mais vraiment avec un
engagement
on peut pas dire que les Allemands de
Dortmund était nettement supérieur
puisque le Paris-Saint-Germain a failli
faire la différence malheureusement ça
s'est fait à la quasiment dernière
minute donc pour dire qu'on a vu
assister à un très beau match de foot et
ce que je tiens à préciser également
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de leçons à
tirer également pour le football
masculin en ce sens où c'est très fluide
il y a très peu d'arrêt de jeu et en
même temps très peu de protestations
très peu d'arrêt de jeu
pourtant c'est assez on va dire viril
virilologique et en même temps c'est
très propre en ce sens où on voit bien
qu'ils sont confrontés autour du foot
autour du ballon et il y a pas un
problème de personne donc il y a pas de
rivalité à chaque fois quand il y a des
confrontations quand il y a des duels au
football on aime les duels parce que
c'est là que ça se passe finalement la
rivalité se passe dans des duels autour
d'un ballon avec les féminin on sent la
rivalité sur le ballon dans le duel
footballistique mais pas du tout de
rapport aux coéquipières voire en
concurrente et là je pense qu'on a
vraiment des choses à apprendre c'est la
raison pour laquelle je prône le
football au féminin dans les clubs parce
qu'on a tous à y gagner
alors on a un embryon d'équipe
simplement on n'avait pas de terrain
jusqu'à maintenant donc je l'annonce
c'est pour cette année on devrait avoir
un terrain de football pour le mois de
septembre ça se joue sur le même terrain
ça se joue pas en même temps et en même
temps ça nécessite du logistique tout
simplement et comme on a très très peu
de terrain pour plus de 1000 licenciés
je le précise encore au téléspectateurs
qui nous regardent il a fallu attendre
un terrain pour le dédier d'abord au
féminin pour l'organisation et on y
mettra bien évidemment les garçons
ensuite c'est quand même un football un
peu plus lent que le football
professionnel
j'ai pas j'ai pas eu le sentiment d'une
lenteur quelconque c'est jusqu'au
contraire c'est beaucoup plus fluide il
y a très peu d'arêtes de jeu plus lent
j'ai pas eu ce sentiment en le regardant
j'ai sentiments vous avez regardé non
j'ai pas regardé mais j'en ai regardé
d'autres et je trouve ça pas moins
attractif même j'aurais tendance à
regarder plus volontiers en football un
football féminin je trouve que c'est
plus réfléchi plus propre plus tactique
il y a moins d'égo en jeu et non je
pense que c'est vraiment le football de
demain
alors sur le plan technique moi je suis
effectivement Sephora dans son analyse
mais je suis pas un grand technicien sur
le plan esthétique le beach volley
féminin m'intéresse plus
mais c'est vrai que après si par exemple
Roland Garros transmettez que les matchs
féminins il y aurait probablement moins
d'audience non probablement bien sûr
mais cela étant un bémol pour le coup
Sephora c'est que là on parle on parle
football pour avoir regardé le Real
Madrid
sur la stratégie il y a beaucoup quand
même
on y voit pas on y voit pas toutes ces
stratégies qui sont menées réellement
avec des attaques en zone avec des
déplacements dans les dans les
intervalles on voit bien que par exemple
Barça à ce niveau là vraiment beaucoup
de choses à apprendre à faire passer
dans le football en général qui soit
masculin ou féminin donc j'irai pas
jusqu'à dire que c'était souvent des
derrière
des enseignements de longue date le
football féminin voilà amorce mais en
tout cas c'est un début et c'est très
prometteur probablement
on a fini là-dessus
peut-être qu'on peut parler alors dans
d'autres sujets qui vous passionne c'est
les élections régionales
non parce qu'on sait quand même quelque
chose d'assez extraordinaire c'est à
dire que il y avait deux deux candidats
pour le Parti socialiste qui était
Jean-Paul Husson le candidat sortant et
Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie qui était la
première vice-présidente du conseil
régional qui était tous les deux voués à
faire une primaire et puis Claude
Barcelone est arrivé là-dessus président
de l'Assemblée a dit je vais vous mettre
tout le monde d'accord et je vais me
présenter au début Jean-Paul Luchon a
fait interview dans le monde qui est
assez sidérante où il dit on n'est pas
question je ne me retirerais pas il
laisse entendre enfin sauf si on me
donne quelque chose et tout d'un coup il
se retire je sais pas comment on peut
analyser ça est-ce que c'est comme la
vieille politique
des articles liés à cette affaire on
voit bien que Monsieur Huchon a obtenu
satisfaction sur la totalité des
demandes qu'il avait fait l'une d'entre
elles d'ailleurs étaient de payer les
avocats qui
continuent de le défendre dans une
affaire pas très propre et donc bah oui
faut lire la presse toute la presse et
donc évidemment que quand on a un peu
l'information on se rend compte que
Monsieur Luchon a eu satisfaction dans
la totalité de ses demandes d'où son
retrait au profit de Monsieur bartholon
en même temps Monsieur Jean était une
personnalité
usée
trois mandats bien sûr ça
use et en plus avec des résultats sur le
plan régional qui sont pas probants par
conséquent il était temps de changer de
personnalité la vice-présidente n'avait
pas probablement le charisme et
l'envergure
utile à pouvoir prétendre
gagner contre donc il fallait un gros
calibre on est allé chercher Bertha
berthelen qui a accepté voilà point
la ça s'était politique là c'est
précisément celle que rejette tous les
Français
je trouve ça effectivement un peu
curieux et d'abord la première chose que
je trouvais étonnante c'est qu'on
abandonne la présidence de la facon on
imagine que Barcelone abandonnerait si
jamais il était élu président de
l'Assemblée nationale qui est quand même
un poste où on est le deuxième ou
troisième personnage de l'État pour
diriger la région et c'est très bien
Virgil région mais donc je trouve ça un
peu un peu troublant parce que c'est
quand même un poste merveilleux et puis
ensuite ce qui m'inquiète c'est je
rejoins un petit peu notre ami là sur la
politique à l'ancienne c'est que si j'ai
bien compris il a pas annoncé qui qui
trait l'Assemblée nationale quoi qu'il
se passe c'est-à-dire que
si il est pas élu
parce que je trouve quand même assez
curieux d'être président de l'Assemblée
nationale de se présenter au suffrage
universel et puis finalement
éventuellement d'être battus
le reste finalement le
j'ai pas grand chose à rajouter pour le
coup
rien de nouveau rien c'est ça rien de
surprenant ni dans un sens ni dans l'eau
avec avec le président de la République
puisque on a appris que que Jean-Paul
scho serait reçu par François Hollande
et donc on va voir
je crois que c'est soit la présidence du
Conseil économique et social soit
devenir ministre donc quand je disais on
verra bien on verra bien s'il y a s'il y
a une un échange parce que François
Hollande avait quand même dit moi
Président je me mêlerai pas du tout il
s'en émet les directement quand même ça
c'est je pense qu'on peut pas dire
mais bien évidemment c'est normal qu'il
s'en mêle ce qui était anormal c'est que
c'est qu'il ose faire croire qu'il ne
s'en mêlerait pas
je trouve ça vraiment trop blanc mais
l'autre fait un peu curieux c'est que à
gauche c'est juste une question de
personnes c'est-à-dire que c'est ce
matin on a entendu encore Bartolone
s'exprimer etc à aucun moment il y a une
sorte de révolution en disant bah voilà
on change d'époque on va faire ça et on
propose de faire ça non c'est juste
effectivement euchon est peut-être usé
alors on le change il s'engueule avec sa
première vie président moi j'arrive en
fait ils vont faire la même chose donc
je sais pas si c'est bien
si on veut gagner il faut qu'on récupère
les écolos le Front de Gauche les les
contestataires du PS et voilà Monsieur
ce serait bien que pour faire de la
politique à gauche comme à droite on
finisse par se dire que ce serait bien
d'abord d'avoir un programme avant juste
de dire on change tel pion celui-là une
tête plus sympathique celle-là
s'engueule
trouvez pas juste décevant parce que une
chose c'était quand même le bras droit
de Michel Rocard pendant des années
c'est-à-dire que ça a gardé justement
une morale
une autre façon de la nouvelle la
deuxième gauche une autre façon de faire
de la politique
il a quasiment aidé à tuer tous les
requins et donc là de Fabius pendant
longtemps et donc là il achève le boulot
même si effectivement ils sont étaient
plus regardés depuis longtemps mais là
c'est resté un soupçon de regarder
là c'est fini pardon Mustapha non ma
boîte de toute façon il est clair que
Turin n'a aucune chance contre Bartolone
pardon Barcelone
en puissance contre Pécresse le match au
sommet aura lieu de toute façon non on
voit bien qu'à un moment donné
on se retrouve quand même ce type de
pointure Pécresse à droite c'est
également un problème de personne
puisque après tout ils ont fait leur
sélection avant même de présenter le
programme à droite à gauche de la même
façon soleil ton on le retrouve
également dans tous les états majeurs si
bien dans nos communes on prend la
commune de Trappes par exemple on voit
bien qui est arrivé à un moment donné
pour s'implanter à Trappes on va bien
que les également c'est vrai pour les
départementales c'est vrai pour les
régénère donc on a la s’en étonner aussi
simplement c'est effectivement comme ça
que ça se pratique et à partir du moment
où il y a quelques personnes qui peuvent
émerger il y a moi je le sens entre les
cas par exemple sur une commune comme
trap encore une fois on sent bien qu'il
y a des gens qui ont envie de faire
changer la société quand on a envie de
dire j'ai probablement un message à
faire passer j'ai même une équipe en
place qui pourrait travailler mais on
voit bien qu'on est face à un obstacle
qui est celui de des états majeurs qui
n'hésitent pas en prêt élection et même
avant les élections à flinguer toutes
les têtes qui veulent bien émerger et ça
c'est des discours que j'ai dans
pratiquement toutes les communes où j'ai
pu exercer en qualité de président du
club de foot et on voit bien que c'est
assez
on va dire
déstructurant la manière dont sa
pratique effectivement il y a des gens
pour les gens mais c'est voilà c'est
très insidieux c'est très voilà je vais
pas apporter ici également de ce que
j'avance mais c'est vrai que quand il y
a un état majeur qui se met en place qui
soit de droite ou de gauche ça se passe
avec le Parti socialiste avec le parti
avec l'UMP c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai toujours reprenais pour le EPS
comme vous le savez et probablement que
dans l'UMPS on aurait pu faire émerger
en plus des gens qui seraient pas issus
maintenant
puisque Sarkozy a trouvé le moyen
d'éviter le piège de l'UMPS en allant
chercher un titre différent mais tu
parlais d'hommes tout à l'heure de la
même façon à droite on parle de Sarkozy
et point à la ligne à la région on va
parler de maintenant de Pékin
également
donc on voit bien qu'il y a aussi ce jeu
dans les deux dans les deux camps et
cette bonne guerre simplement je
voudrais qu'on parle de ces gens de la
société civile donc tu parles souvent
autour de cette chaîne avec brioche
les corps intermédiaires
les faire émerger
je suis ravi que ça prenne légèrement la
mode profondeur tout ça
d'avoir un adhérent mais je fais partie
de cela et tu le sais et c'est très
compliqué
les gens votent probablement c'est que
maintenant les gens s'actionnent alors
peut-être que l'abstention et le j'ai
envie de dire de le le dénominateur
commun le dénominateur commun
si je me souviens le dénominateur commun
des abstentionnistes ça serait bien
cette idée que effectivement ce sont les
parties avec très peu de gens qui font
la carte graphique
on recevra
représentant d'un nouveau parti de la
semaine prochaine donc on en parlera
peut-être avec lui il y a un nom que
vous n'avez pas prononcé mais puisque
vous pouvez aller le trap c'est amont
parce que à mon un moment on a parlé de
lui que pour prendre la tête de la liste
des résultats ce qui était assez curieux
pour quelqu'un qui avait quand même
démissionné avec fracas qui avait été
mis dehors du gouvernement avec fracas
mais enfin voilà
la députation de la même façon il est
arrivé et tout le monde sait de se
demander mais pourquoi faire pour être
député certes on l'a vu probablement
pour l'Amérique trap mais on avait pensé
à l'Île-de-France je sais pas je ne les
suis pas de l'intérieur alors
Jean-Charles qu'est-ce que tu en penses
on va peut-être parler de parce que il y
a donc bartolovago je vais les répéteras
à droite qui a lancé sa campagne on
regarde et puis on en parle juste après
propose que ce mois de mai soit consacré
à ce que on prenne bien conscience que
en 17 ans les contes qu'ils ont à rendre
au franciliens sont mauvais là vous
prenez de l'avant sur le PS et je les
oblige surtout à essayer de faire le
bilan de la façon dont ils ont géré 11
milliards et demi d'euros d'argent
public
financer tout ça on supprimant les 75%
de réduction aux étrangers en situation
irrégulière je suis pas sûr que ça
suffit ça financer tout ça parfois non
elle devrait quand même dire aux
francilien et à la France entière que
l'Île-de-France est la première région
économique de France que c'est un budget
colossal et que à l'intérieur de ce
budget effectivement il y a des
répartitions qui ne favorisent pas le
développement économique de
l'Île-de-France j'en prends un en
particulier qu'est-ce qu'on appelle le
commerce digital
c'est dans le domaine du commerce une
révolution qui est en train de se faire
aujourd'hui
devant nous sans que se rendre compte
d'ailleurs des conséquences que ça aura
on en parle de temps en temps sur
l'emploi sur l'économie sur
l'organisation même d'une région et d'un
pays et là personne ne prend la mesure
de cette situation je trouve que c'est
important de parler de transport en
Île-de-France on est en retard de parler
de tourisme de parler d'emploi de parler
de formation de parler de culture mais
on ne parle pas de commerce digital
c'est très grave parce que de toute
façon l'Île-de-France va être par nature
la locomotive dans cette révolution
sur le fait aussi qu'elle veuille
déménager vous avez vu qu'elle veut
déménager
du conseil régional à Paris je peux vous
dire que c'est effectivement la luxe
inouï et que il est grand grand temps de
fréquente ces bureaux là assez
fréquemment et je peux vous assurer que
on y vit dans un confort tout à fait
inadapté à la situation dans laquelle se
trouve notre pays aujourd'hui
puisqu'on parlait de Trappes
qu'on revienne sur la ferme Moussa enfin
le le
la mort de ce jeune jeune garçon c'est
quoi l'état d'esprit aujourd'hui puisque
vous vivez à Trappes
est-ce que voilà c'est une guerre entre
quartiers c'est contrebande c'est quoi
exactement
alors la ferme moussens c'est jamais que
la partie immergée de l'iceberg puisque
c'est un événement c'est une
déflagration qu'on a tous pour le coup
subi aussi puisque
ce mort intervient dans sur un fond de
bandes rivales sur un fond de rivalité
de cité qui est là depuis maintenant
quelques années tout le monde le sait je
crois faut commencer par le dire ce qui
est arrivé personne ne l'aurait imaginé
mais on aurait pu au moins éviter
certaines choses qui a amené à ce décès
tout le monde le sait tout le monde sait
que c'est que les cités de Trappes sont
entrés en rivalité
et en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que
c'est pour le coup pas une balle perdue
parce qu'il y a eu quand même il y a eu
une intention on a bien vu que c'était
une voiture qui s'est positionnée face à
un groupe et qui a tiré donc ça quand
même ça reste un message ça reste
libérer et ça reste un message comme tu
dis c'est pas une balle simplement
donc là il y a un vrai message
simplement ce message c'est aussi que en
tout cas moi celui que je lance c'est
que il se passe des choses sur la ville
de Trappes mais que ça reste quand même
je tiens à le dire j'y vis voilà
la mentalités
on a parlé de guerre à un moment donné
autour de cette table on a parlé de
guerre on peut pas j'ai parlé de guerre
éventuellement de de clan ou de guerre
de de citer cela étant il y a un mot qui
revient pas assez souvent quand on parle
des quartiers c'est la paix qui règne et
pour aller pour marquer les esprits j'ai
envie de dire que la majorité des gens
qui vivent mériteraient le prix Nobel de
la paix en restant dans une situation
comme celle-là aussi tendue aussi
effroyable mais qui vit dans ces
quartiers qui vivent en ces HLM moi je
suis allé voir la famille Moussa
longtemps après que tout le monde soit
parti parce que on est allé témoigner
pour le club de foot mais tu es allé
voir également Daouda c'est-à-dire qu'on
parle de la victime qui a pris une balle
on parle plus du tout de Daouda qui a
pris une balle dans la jambe on parle
pas non plus des dizaines de personnes
qu'on entendu eux la déflagration
physiquement moi je parle de
déflagration j'ai presque envie de dire
de déflagration
politique mais tous ces gens-là ont été
meurtris ont été frappés dans leur chair
un une balle qui l'a tué un dans la
jambe et d'autres qui ont assisté à la
scène et qui ont vu le gamin le gamin
tomber mais tous les gens qui vivent
dans cette cité ils y vivent avant
l'événement après et ils vivent dans un
dans une tolérance dans un climat de
paix dans un apaisement où tout le monde
appelle à l'apaisement d'ailleurs le
père qui est intervenu pour appeler à
l'apaisement le père de Daouda cette
fois-ci qui appelle à l'apaisement a été
d'une dignité absolument remarquable la
marche qui a été engagée pour pour dire
pour témoigner en tous les cas la
famille le soutien à la famille était
d'une dignité absolue mais c'est vrai
que le problème demeure c'est à dire que
Moussa est mort il est une victime
collatérale non pas d'une balle perdue
mais d'un message simplement le problème
demeure et qu'est-ce qu'on fait et là je
fais un appel encore une fois et un
appel que je voudrais même officialiser
sous forme de d'un comment dire d'un
d'une association ou peut-être même d'un
d'un appel tout court c'est-à-dire je
pense que nous les présidents entre les
cas passionnés par l'éducation et le
loisir dans les cités il faudrait qu'on
soit un peu plus entendu ça coûterait
beaucoup moins cher
être entendu parce que je prends le club
de foot on est totalement épargné par
cette violence parce que à l'intérieur
voilà c'est complètement les quartiers
les quartiers dont on parle le quartier
où est mort Moussa Moussa était un
joueur du club Daouda est un joueur du
club mais ceux qui habitent dans le
quartier entre guillemets rival les deux
quartiers ont leurs amis dans les autres
quartiers donc il s'est complètement
interconnecté c'est entremêler et
pourtant on est ép au club de foot
pourquoi parce que
vous avez des joueurs des deux quartiers
plus de 1000 adhérents sur la commune de
Trappes il y a pas pratiquement pas un
gamin qui ne joue pas au club et on est
totalement épargné pourquoi parce que
l'objet foot fait son boulot les
éducateurs font leur boulot et quand je
disais la dernière fois que les
éducateurs étaient payés on prenait
quasiment 50 centimes pour s'occuper du
football à trappe et que les éducateurs
étaient payés quasiment 200-300 euros de
dédommagement quand je vous disais qu'il
faisait leur travail sur le terrain mais
qu'en plus ils étaient dans les
quartiers il faut savoir qu'ils sont
dans les quartiers encore maintenant
avant et après ces événements et il
continue à faire ce travail et on n'est
pas forcément pas forcément écouté je
lance donc un appel malheureusement voir
un appel à toutes les associations de
Trappes puisque ce groupe voilà donc je
lance justement cette ce fameux appel
comment ça se fait qu'on vous entende
pas plus parce que évidemment vous
faites vous et d'autres faites un boulot
formidable alors on a entendu surtout
sur sur TV film puisque c'est souvent
que je viens sur cette antenne et on a
parlé de vous sur TF1 on a parlé de vous
etc il y a des médicaments
les gens qui devraient vous aider qui
sont ne vous écoute pas plus je n'ai pas
de vous personnellement je parle de tous
les associations
je lance un je lance donc un collectif
qu'on va appeler appelle donc j'ai envie
de dire c'est l'appel des présidents
passionnés par l'éducation et le loisir
et on sait très bien que l'éducation
passe par le loisir et que le loisir ne
doit pas être simplement un loisir dans
lequel on met de l'argent et on
entretient pas ce fait fédérateur se
fait éducatif cet appel que je lance je
le lance à tous les présidents
d'associations puisque ça soit de la
culture ou du sport et quand je parle
avec tous ces présidents je me rends
compte qu'effectivement isolément ils
essaient de faire des choses ils sont
pas forcément entendus alors on va
probablement se regrouper et j'espère
qu'on sera retenu parce que l'idée c'est
si un gamin
quitte une structure la mienne ou une
autre structure qui ne se déstructure
pas et on a parlé ici autour de cette
table des gens qui sont partis
déstructurés par le biais d'Internet qui
se sont retrouvés perdus dans des
contrées lointaines la destructuration
de l'enfance c'est souvent le fait qu'il
ait quitté une structure que ça soit
celle du foot que ça soit celle de
d'associations culturelles ou sportive
et donc mon appel il est là c'est crayon
un maillage d'associations donc des
présidents passionnés par l'éducation et
loisirs et là je lance un appel comme tu
sais si bien de faire
Jean-Luc à cette mobilisation des
présidents aussi aussi pour être
entendus donc on va pas faire contre qui
que ce soit mais on va faire pour la
population pour les enfants et faire en
sorte que des enfants qui quittent une
structure ne se déstructurent pas ils se
retrouvent voilà accompagner l'éducation
au coeur de la société sont suscept
extrêmement important mais l'éducation
c'est aussi la capacité de pouvoir
instruire nos jeunes filles et garçons à
ouvrir les bras attendre la main or là
ce que dit Mustapha est extrêmement
passionnant et très grave parce que en
fait on n'a rien désamorcé il y a un
message lancé par un clan il y aura un
message lancé par l'autre et là son
c'est bien que c'était véritable donc
vite vite remettre l'éducation la
culture l'ouverture tendre la main
ouvrir les bras au cœur de ces sociétés
qui sont aujourd'hui malheureusement
largement manipulées et j'ai même
entendu j'en ai parlé avec Mustapha des
gens du quartier Albert Camus puisque
c'est de là dont il s'agit qui disent
mais toute façon ils nous ont mis ça
parce qu'ils veulent nous mettre dehors
ils veulent raser ce quartier pour faire
autre chose et donc les gens aujourd'hui
malheureusement au quotidien depuis la
date de l'assassinat de ce jeune garçon
vivent dans la peur
voilà c'est pour ça que je tiens quand
même insister pour dire que les gens de
Trappes y habitent au quotidien et
vraiment c'est voilà si le prix Nobel de
la Paix pouvait te donner à chacun
d'entre eux pour y vivre et maintenir
ça serait bien en tous les cas en tout
cas à la candidature
de cet appel association des présidents
passionnés par l'éducation et les
loisirs je suis passionné par l'histoire
aussi donc le clin d'oeil ça sera
improbablement pour le 18 juin voilà
j'espère que tes véciles participera
est acteur avec toi moi j'ai fait un sms
pour prévenir
au maire mais il faut qu'il soit à
fourgon
il faut être président de quelque chose
oui est-ce que c'est ouvert tous les
gens de bonne volonté là en dehors de je
voulais pas monopoliser la parole
pour le coup voilà ça reste un symbole
c'est un c'est une liste que je voudrais
ouvrir un espèce de collectif parce que
l'association c'est encore un président
un secrétaire une ligne politique etc
donc c'est plutôt
voilà c'est plutôt nous rassemblons-nous
de façon rassembler les associations
quoi alors l'appel bah c'est le titre
l'appel du 18 juin pour une résistance
assez malheurs une résistance à tout ce
qu'on peut offrir et puis aussi Patrice
je dis que c'est pas contre quelqu'un
mais c'est pour mais il y a aussi
possibilité de passer au travers des
fonds pour le coup des fonds publics
parce que tous les fonds publics sont en
baisse la qu'est-ce qui vient de baisser
de 30% et n'est pas de la compétence de
la casquille pour donner des fonds au
club de foot par exemple donc on a des
subventions qui baissent pour toutes les
associations moi je vais pas attendre de
ne plus avoir de fond de la collectivité
donc il va bien falloir qu'on passe
également par les fonds privés et le
privé je pense qu'il y a un discours
alors à leur offrir et le fait de créer
des collectifs pour aller chercher
également des fonds et pour les faire
participer allez on va dire de en
qualité d'entreprise citoyenne mais
c'est un peu galvaudé maintenant l'idée
c'est de faire participer aussi
l'entreprise qui participent déjà
beaucoup à la collectivité c'est pas
Jean-Luc qui me dira participent pas par
le biais de des taxes de la TVA et
toutes les charges qui pèsent sur les
entreprises mais ça serait une manière
détournée de faire en sorte qu'on sache
où vont nos taxes c'est-à-dire que quand
tu payes pas la TVA et quand tu payes
pas l'impôt en le donnant aux
associations par définition tu peux
participer à une vie collective sans
passer par le principe des charges moi
je prône donc la pelle l'association des
présidents passionnés parce que je
voudrais faire appel à des structures
mais globalement si le basket et là si
Déclic Théâtre est là si black bombers
est là si les associés les grosses
structures de de sport et de culture
sont là mais également les locataires de
Trappes sont là alors ça fera
probablement la totalité de la commune
mais encore une fois il y a des
économies d'échelle à faire il y a des
il y a des choses qui sont saupoudrés on
peut trouver des économies d'échelle à
faire par exemple j'ai des moyens pour
le club de foot que je peux mettre à la
disposition d'autres clubs donc des
économies d'échelle on fait jouer les
filles c'est moins cher au football
et on pourra que ça
démission spéciale là dessus
trois mots sur le sujet vous voyez
j'insiste beaucoup toujours sur la
faiblesse des corps intermédiaires du
coup on crée des collectifs dans tous
les sens c'est le résultat de la France
pour aller dans le sens de Mustapha moi
je lance un appel personnel à Guy
Malandain que j'aime beaucoup pour
lequel j'ai une admiration depuis très
très longtemps je le connais depuis 25
ans que je suis installé dans la ville
nouvelle et je lance un appel personnel
à Guy Malandain pour qu'il rejoignent
l'association appel de Mustapha parce
que je considère que cet homme a fait
beaucoup pour sa ville très concrètement
on parle peu de lui ça donne discret
mais il a été une étiquette peut-être
les gens qui sont aussi dans
l'opposition
l'objet l'objet hors politique puisque
c'est juste faire d'association pour des
économies d'échelle et faire des
propositions et encore une fois c'est
cette idée selon l'enfant dans un
parcours quand il trébuche tombe dans
une nasse et pour le coup qui soit
rattrapé par la collectivité c'est un
peu le Conseil d'orientation des
associations qu'on pourrait imaginer
voire même des labels de sérieux qu'on
pourrait apporter aux collectivités pour
dire voilà on est sérieux
alors c'est une façon de parler aussi de
la République ça de la laïcité de la
citoyenneté en tout cas et François vous
lui rajouter quelque chose là
les trois ans de 3 ans de mandat alors
on voit bien qu'ils politiques de
communication vis-à-vis des jeunes de la
même façon que Mitterrand a fait ça au
86 on dit qu'est-ce qu'a fait midi en 86
il a récupéré les jeunes donc on va
faire pareil pour essayer de de remonter
la porte des sondages et donc il a fêté
les trois autres sondages avec des
jeunes je voudrais qu'on regarde une
photo une photo voilà alors parmi ces
jeunes il y avait une jeune fille voilà
qui est tout à fait son droit qui était
voilé mais est-ce qu'il y a pas une
contradiction à nous parler toute la
journée de République de laïcité et de
fêter les trois ans de son mandat avec
une jeune fille voilée
qui veut est-ce que les voilées vraiment
est-ce que le fait d'avoir à vous
foulard sur la tête
moi je suis breton et encore aujourd'hui
il y a beaucoup de femmes en Bretagne
qui se mettent en fleur
mais pas pour fêter les trois ans
elle est sur le site de l'Élysée par les
résultats
dans le cadre d'une école ou une
institution publique on aurait dit bon
c'est contre la loi parce que nanani
nanana mais si c'est
pas
non non c'est sur le symbole
on n'a jamais autant parlé au
gouvernement de République de laïcité et
voilà c'est aussi c'est aussi un symbole
de de faire ça avec une jeune fille qui
voit les limites le symbole il est
qu'effectivement le président de la
République dans la main une personne
pour tout le monde enfin doit se tendre
pour le coup non la main doit être
tendue vers les uns vers les autres il y
a des lois je pense qu'à un moment donné
il faut qu'on arrête focaliser sur sur
on est quasiment dans l'hystérieuse
on est dans le domaine de l'image et de
ce qu'on veut montrer c'est à dire que
là le président de la République parle
sans arrêt de laïcité d'ouverture de
tranquillité d'apaisement il choisit
trois jeunes et sur les trois jeunes il
y a une femme
c'est quand même un peu curieux je veux
dire quel est le message qu'est-ce qu'on
dit alors on comprend bien que il essaie
de ramasser large et que et qui se dit
bah voilà avec cette petite photo je
vais acheter les banlieues après on
rendra le vote obligatoire ils vont tous
voter pour moi bon c'est une théorie
mais ça grandit pas le bonhomme et c'est
franchement c'est un argument enfin je
veux dire qui doit mettre la moitié des
gens hors 2 ça veut dire pourquoi avoir
choisi la dernière fois on parlait
justement de prôner une politique de
l'affrontement ou alors une politique
d'unité moi je pense que c'est par là
l'occasion d'aller vers une politique de
l'unité on parlait justement que le
manque d'éducation le manque de culture
amené au rejet et à la peur de l'autre
on encourageait justement au fait de
tendre la main et d'être autolérant et
d'être ouvert moi je pense au contraire
que c'est une bonne chose
Jean-Charles sur le symbole donc encore
une fois c'est une moto c'est pas du
deuxième main deuxièmement je reprends
tes propres arguments
bien dans le principe de la République
de la laïcité tu as vu une connotation
religieuse à cette photo d'accord
ou très puissante pour ma part pour ma
part ce sont trois jeunes gens qui tend
la main et pour le coup même si je le
vois je ne le remarque pas je ne le
prône pas c'est je ne mets pas ça en
évidence j'ai vu des mains tendues je
suis resté sur les mains tendues mais tu
as raison il y a probablement un
prosélytisme de sa part comme il y en a
peut-être des deux autres
quand elles ont une coiffe on dit tiens
ce que je veux dire c'est que on voit
pas tous la même chose et c'est ça qui
est important moi j'ai vu un président
dans la main mais pourquoi en être
choqué cette femme en l'occurrence je
sais même pas ce qu'elle dit je serais
curieux de l'Entente pour dire
éventuellement je suis d'accord avec
elle je l'entends pas je sais pas ce
qu'elle fait pour dire si éventuellement
je suis pas d'accord avec elle je ne la
vois pas faire non plus donc on parle
d'une photo et on est sensibilisé comme
chacun à ses propres perceptions tu as
cette perception cette sensibilité à te
ramener sur le dos
très jolie mais et je n'ai vu qu'une
main tendue du président de la
République moi je constate simplement
que François Hollande quand il pense à
la jeunesse machin il y a forcément une
femme voilée voilà c'est tout c'est
c'est ça
si c’est alors probablement que c'est
peut-être le tiers c'est peut-être le
tiers de tiers le tiers état pourquoi
penser une religieuse alors qu'on a le
tiers état le clergé et la noblesse
c'est une partie de la France qui
représentait le fer religieux c'était
donc un tiers donc un tiers de la France
serait voilé non c'est parce que
religieux
il y a des Juifs des orthodoxes je suis
pas intimement persuadé que toutes les
autres religions se sentent parfaitement
représentées par cette femme
j'ai parlé
immense si c'était une fille les filles
n'ont pas de qui pas mais un mec avec
une kippa ou une bonne sœur cistercienne
je sais pas ça m'aurait choqué de la
même façon c'est passé c'est pas un truc
anti-musulman c'est un truc laïcité si
on parle sans arrêt là il citer on
respecte le pouvoir
mais sinon
fait que les religions peuvent
s'exprimer librement dans un pays laïque
totalement d'accord et on parle bien
trop de religion je trouve dans ce pays
là voilà c'est là où je voulais en venir
c'est que globalement la laïcité c'est
vraiment un élément fondateur d'une
République dans laquelle je vis et que
je prône au quotidien puisque je parle
souvent de l'objet foot qui est laïque
républicain donc c'est pas moi qui vais
rentrer entre guillemets dans l'anti
pour le coup laïcité ou prenait quelques
religions quelques religions que ce soit
ou le fait religion particuliers je
trouve simplement qu'on en parle trop
qu'on se braque facilement et que c'est
c'est cette tendance là qui fait que de
toute façon on va sur la gueule
parce que personne lâchera personne
lâchera moi je demande à ce qu'on se
détende tous l'idée n'est pas de lâcher
parce que de toute façon tout a été
lâché déjà
maintenant que est-ce que est-ce que il
existe plus de justice de police est-ce
qu'il y a plus de faire répréhensible on
parle de voile et que je sache à mon
avis elle n'est pas hors-la-loi dans ce
qu'elle fait non non non on est dans le
symbole et ben moi dans le symbole j'ai
vu une main tendu tu as vu le voile et
toi comme quoi sur la même photo on peut
voir deux choses totalement différentes
une photo
tout à fait acceptable c'est-à-dire que
je pense que ça n'arrivera jamais
malheureusement mais j'espère un jour
que nos petits petits enfants verront
avant tout dans l'autre un humain
au-delà du fait de voir une origine une
religion ou je ne sais quoi verront
avant tout un humain parce qu'à la base
je pense que c'est c'est ce qui nous sur
cette planète
peuvent avoir des revendications
d'autres pas une appartenance
mais ça ça
caractérise d'appartenance ou pas
sur le torse on revendique le fait
d'être chrétien revendique c'est tout
donc quand on est avec un voile on
revendique le fait de porter un voile
c'est pas un hasard c'est pas c'est
c'est pas un béret basse parce qu'on a
fait du tourisme
quelque chose autrement elle se sent
bien comme ça sans revendiquer elle ne
prend pour elle et elle revendique rien
pour autrui premièrement ce que je
reproche c'est le choix de François
Hollande et tout j'ai vu encore une fois
il m'a entendu dans les signes
ostentatosantoirs dont on parle le temps
moi je pars du principe que les gens se
font d'abord plaisir à eux-mêmes sans
forcément revendiquer il y a pas une
politisation personnelle à chaque fois
que les gens le font je dis pas qu'il y
en a pas qu'ils le font pas et qui a pas
même des extrémistes qui vont au delà
des simples partis politiques parce
qu'on peut parler même de fascisme
pour certains donc je suis pas naïf sur
le sujet simplement à chaque fois que je
vois une femme voilée dans ma pharmacie
dans la rue je n'imagine pas qu'elle est
à la tête d'un mouvement d'un parfum
qu'elle revendique quoi que ce soit elle
le fait parce qu'elle a des convictions
personnelles et elle le porte bien ça
c'est la première chose et là deuxième
chose encore une fois ça me gêne pas si
elle veut revendiquer je suis pas obligé
d'adhérer elle revendique
un certain nombre de femmes alors sur le
sur l'égalité entre les hommes sur la
liberté de la femme ça génère un certain
nombre de femmes de féministes notamment
non mais moi
j'entends deux discours pour le coup
j'écoute beaucoup aussi là on est là
pour parler
je suis reporter terrain moi je voulais
toujours dit ici au tour de cette table
mais quand j'écoute la majorité vous
disent que c'est préserver une certaine
féminité aussi c'est à dire que si la
féminité c'est la cacher aux autres et
la cacher à ce pour lequel elles ont pas
envie de le dévoiler voilà les propos
qu'on peut entendre mais moi je vais pas
rentrer dans ce débat parce que je suis
plutôt partisan effectivement d'une
d'une féminité plus voilà absolument
plus apparente
mais alors dans ce cas là parlons de
parlons dans ce cas la décétisme parlons
d'esthétisme parlons de féminisation
ayant ce débat sur la féminisation sur
même l'esthétique tous ces sujets là
mais l'idée selon laquelle il y aura une
revendication permanente qu'on dirait
vers des conflits pour le coup
du fait religieux pour moi c'est très
important sur LM j'aime pas et puis
qu'on fasse discuter les femmes entre
elles parce que a priori
mais je suis aussi convaincu qu'il y a
beaucoup d'hommes qui sont de cet avis
c'est pour ça donc on peut se rejoindre
parce que ça existe aussi mais ne
caricaturons pas non plus et c'est en ça
que je dis décris spons c'est à dire que
la majorité des femmes vous disent je le
fais franchement j'ai pas envie j'ai pas
envie que tu m'aides
un peu crispé parce que c'est mais non
parce que le débat était juste de dire
c'est un choix curieux du président de
la République sa vision de la jeunesse
c'est-à-dire que sur trois personnes il
y en a une qui voit les voilà
la France c'est pas une personne sur
trois voilées mais la France c'est aussi
des mesures aujourd'hui et la France
c'est aussi des jeunes filles voilées
c'est la France du jour c'est aussi des
bouddhistes et tout ça pourquoi il y a
pas de bouddhisme
représentatif
le fait religieux un tiers très bien
représenté le fait religieux et non pas
la représentation des cultes encore une
fois d'ailleurs il y a un mecs
on peut on peut revoir
à une autre main tendue c'est-à-dire que
c'est la fraternité c'est le symbole
juste de l'amitié de la fraternité on se
retrouve et encore une fois la
République est content
d'accueillir tous ces enfants au lieu de
cette photo il avait présenté la courbe
du chômage nous aurions parlé du chômage
et j'aurais trouvé ça beaucoup plus
intéressant parce que ça engage beaucoup
plus votre société que le fait de savoir
qui est en Lama acquis donc
une courbe du chômage qui a été
présentée à l'occasion de cet
anniversaire formidable
cet anniversaire de 3 ans il y a une
politique de communication et que cette
photo là comme d'autres enfin il le fait
de rencontrer jeune c'est aussi une
façon de communiquer c'est aussi un
symbole de la communication mais il
cherche pas et quand il communique je
pense qu'il Paris préfère rencontrer des
jeunes que de montrer la combustion ah
d'accord donc il y a une attention ah je
pense qu'il y a une attention
le message je suis là il faut vraiment
arrêter de se crisperçu
et passer à côté d'une communication
précisément elle est faite pour ça vous
pensez pas que précisément aujourd'hui
de ce que vous entendez bien sûr on est
en train d'éluder les verrez problèmes
de la société celles pour lesquelles on
devrait travailler pour nos enfants nos
petits-enfants ou profit qui marche
immédiate qui n'ont pas d'intérêt
peut-être ici est-ce que est-ce que
puisque vous parlez de symbole et de
crispation est-ce qu'on a raison est-ce
que le Parti socialiste par exemple se
crisper en disant Nicolas Sarkozy au
fond critiqué deux personnalités du
gouvernement ce qui était Christiane
Taubira qui est aussi Najat
Vallaud-Belkacem et le Parti socialiste
a dit tiens c'est quand même bizarre
c'est deux personnes l'une qui voilà
l'autre qui est d'origine marocaine
c'est de la comédien
compte que les vrais sujets de société
ne sont pas
abordé que le renforcement des causes
intermédiaires on en s'en occupe
toujours pas et qu'on est dans le
symbole permanent c'est pas drôle avoir
un avis sur sur un avis sur sur le
boulot du garde des sceaux
pour le coup c'est du même Regis
c’est-à-dire que j’ai vu une main tendue
quelqu'un il y a vu autre chose quand
une ministre allait une beurette propose
quelque chose donc voilà beurette quand
c'est tobirat qui propose certains y
voir la femme de couleur c'est vrai que
c'est pour le coup pour le coup j'ai
Taubira je vois pas une femme de couleur
je vois une garde des sceaux est-ce
qu'elle est bonne est-ce qu'elle est pas
bonne est-ce qu'elle fait des conneries
ou pas
on va se rejoindre mais j'ai le droit de
la critiquer c'est pas parce qu'elle est
noire
c'est encore une fois du même ordre
c'est-à-dire que si nagettes Valo
Belkacem déconne Najat ça existe aussi
si
c'est déconnant ce qu'elle fait bah on
peut effectivement lui dire et que par
exemple le premier secrétaire du Parti
socialiste et évoquer cette idée selon
laquelle on l'a critiquait parce qu'elle
était belle c'est là où c'est choquant
c'est là où je te rejoins la même façon
que même Taubira a eu des assauts la
concernant
j'ai une théorie parce que personne ne
dit on s'attaque à Belkacem parce
qu'elle est d'origine beurre ou à
Taubira parce qu'elle est dans on le dit
pas
d'Elise dit on s'attaque à elle parce
que mais ceux qui l'attaquent mais
disent pas je m'attaque à elle parce que
c'est une beurre on est d'accord il le
dise pas donc probablement les problèmes
de fond probablement que il y a autre
chose c'est probablement on se dit que
si on n'est pas imbibé de la République
française pendant des décennies voire
des siècles on n'est pas en capacité de
proposer des choses pour cette France là
c'est ça qui me laisse c'est ce soupçon
là que je garde quand même j'ai
l'impression que il fallait être imbibé
de la République et de ses aïeux pendant
des siècles pour pouvoir prétendre à
c'est ça à l'aise comme un peu amer mais
en effet elle est capable de faire une
réforme une bonne réforme ou une
mauvaise ce sentiment quand même aller
elle vient pas de chez nous depuis des
millions d'années donc est-ce qu'elle
est en capacité il y a un petit quelque
chose quand même mais il y a peut-être
quelque chose en effet c'est peut-être
pas innocent d'attaquer celle-là non
plus Sephora Nicolas Sarkozy il est pas
connu pour une tolérance extrême
maintenant bon Christiane Taubira elle
fait pas
sur Internet lorsqu'il y avait justement
une dame qui s'est alors qui lui
expliquait au téléphone il était à la
radio qu'elle s'était converti à l'islam
il ne savait pas qu'il était filmé il a
fait une grimace à moi de l'air de dire
elle s'est perdue c'était très clair
c'était bon c'était très visible
maintenant Christiane Taubira de toute
façon elle fait pas l'unanimité donc
peut-être n'aprouve-t-il pas ce qu'elle
propose quand un nagette
Vallaud-Belkacem ça réformes des
collèges non plus moi-même je comprends
pas du tout le bien fou d'être cette
réforme pourtant je ne pense pas être ni
raciste ni quoi que ce soit donc
peut-être que pour le coup Nicolas
Sarkozy il est juste franchement des
accords avec les choix politiques de ces
deux personnages
Sarkozy avait quand même engagé
jeannette Bougrab avant avant que Najat
velo Belkacem face quoi que ce soit très
avis et Rachida Dati et
le préfet
là dessus
il était à côté de Rama Yade et en
dessous il y avait marqué il me fallait
il me fallait une noire voilà tu vois
comme quoi
il faut le dire les téléspectateurs de
savoir j'ai été choisi que pour ça parce
que elle était une fille
demande pourquoi Jean-Luc pourquoi je
dois faire les mois mais la majorité
de dire une monstruosité cela dit ni de
la droite de temps en temps flirt un peu
quand même mais c'est pas des choses en
plaisantant mais malheureusement c'est
une réalité tu confirmes non mais il y a
beaucoup moi
parler de rabahia tout à l'heure c'est
vrai que parfois on met des gens à des
postes parce que ils représentent
quelque chose de visible enfin une
minorité visible ça arrive aussi pour le
coup est-ce que c'est du racisme va
l'envers est-ce que c'est bien peut-être
plutôt bien c'est fou quand Manuel Valls
s'était fait enregistrer à son insu sur
le marché dans l'ensemble faut me
rajouter des blancs causes parce que là
c'est un peu trop
par contre c'est un vrai sujet ça
Patrice la représentativité parce que
finalement six mois
c'est probablement une plaisanterie je
tiens à dire aussi au spectateurs mais
si certains peuvent se reconnaître en
moi dans certains propos mais j'espère
bien que tout le monde se reconnaît pas
en moi que pour ça et quand je parle de
la République je m'adresse aussi bien
malheureusement c'est une émission qui
n'est pas diffusée sur le territoire
national mais mais par Internet on est
lu et regardez dans le monde entier
j'espère bien que je suis reconnu en
Corrèze je suis reconnu en Corse et
probablement de là mais voilà je suis
pas simple
par contre on n'a pas suffisamment
réfléchi on n'est pas allé assez au fond
lorsque la prix des décisions à propos
de la discrimination positive de la
parité homme-femme etc oui absolument
mais ce sont des débats extrêmement
profonds qui nous ont amené à prendre
des décisions parfois contre la nature
de choses et nous n'avons pas
suffisamment eu de recul et de réflexion
sur ces sujets là la discrimination
positive qui a été inscrite aux
États-Unis depuis une bonne trentaine
d'années n'a pas eu de très bons
résultats et on voit à quoi aboutit en
France la parité homme-femme
malheureusement on se rend bien compte
que c'est pourri de faux semblant et que
ça n'a pas amélioré la situation bien au
contraire ça l'attendu j'ai une vraie
interrogation pour le coup sur la notion
de République et à la française en
particulier si je me demande à quel
point la France a les moyens de
valoriser ces pour le coup valoriser ses
vertus c'est à dire que la République
qui prône l'égalité
l'égalité pour le coup et qui donne la
chance à tous il faut des moyens pour ça
le communautarisme a un peu relégué on
parle des États-Unis par exemple un peu
relayer le financement de certaines
choses aux communautés et qui marche
pour le coup pas si mal simplement je le
préconise pas pour la France ça serait
pire
et ça serait pire à mon avis pour les
revenir c'est pour ça que je dis ça mais
probablement que il y a aussi un vrai
sujet c'est qu'il faut avoir les moyens
également de ses propres vertus et de
dire que si on veut offrir à tout le
monde la même chose ça demande des
moyens et on le voit les moyens de
l'éducation nationale on le voit dans la
police on le voit dans l'armée on le
voit dans les corps dans les corps les
corps d'état et pour le coup et pour le
coup le communautarisme souvent joue ce
rôle
donc le communautarisme en fait il est
pas là pour s'imposer souvent
il peut avoir aussi des rôles
surtout si ces vacances
il nous reste à peine deux minutes donc
on va pas aborder un autre sujet parce
qu'on n'aura pas le temps est-ce qu'il y
a peut-être dans l'actualité quelque
chose qui vous a frappé dont vous
vouliez parler
François Hollande c'est merveilleux
quand même
il paraît que c'est un moment historique
de serrer la main de ce que vous avez vu
de ce vieux débris qui est le dernier
foot adidas
le dernier dictateur vivant enfin je
veux dire quelqu'un des des Cuba vous
êtes comme
ça je ne reproche pas du tout à François
Hollande en tant que président de la
République d'être allé là-bas
économiquement c'est sûrement un bon
plan et effectivement une fois qu'on est
là-bas d'aller d'aller voir final Castro
il est pas forcé d'en parler avec des
larmes dans les yeux on se
surtout qu'il avait eu des paroles assez
dures sur quelque chose
je vis nous vivons un moment historique
je sers à la main de façon c'est
terrible enfin rapidement en un mot je
vois pas la même chose je vois le futur
quand on parle du passé
à l'avenir et à sa jeunesse qui veut
effectivement tourner la page il est
allé pour tourner cette page d'histoire
et participer à ce mouvement qui est
celui effectivement du passé
on reproche à Sarkozy de serrer la main
de Kadhafi on peut il faut pas s'étonner
que François voilà
ce qui lui a tourné
merci en tout cas à tous les quatre
voilà l'émission est terminée la semaine
prochaine oui on parlera avec le
représentant d'un nouveau parti
politique qui essaie d'énergie justement
ça vous intéresse j'espère
à la semaine prochaine au revoir